[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants crient le calme ce
soir
oui je me demande ce que font nicolas et
pimprenelle et bien des 100 voire
nounours vous savez patron lorsque les
enfants sont calmes je n'ose pas trop
aller le déranger allons du courage du
courage l'ours dans l'échelle des papes
attend
[Musique]
mais c'est vrai qu'ils sont forts
regarde le monde attendait 6 juil
tu sais bien c'est l'histoire du petit
avis tu la connais pas un ours et bien
mon vote de la chanter il était un petit
navire
il était un petit navire qui n'avait
charge à jamais navigué qui a fait japon
j'ai jamais la vigueur et aux il a
entrepris un long voyage ville hôte
repli à louvois ya je la mets mes
méditerranée cela permet méditerranée
aurait aurait
et au bout de cinq à six semaines
au bout de cinq à six semaines les
vivres au talent à la route a manqué les
libretas parade a manqué oui oh oui
on tue rosa loconte paille au tirage à
la courte paille ou savoie qui qui qui
sera mangé pour savoir qui est qui qui
sera mangé ou et or et le sort tomba sur
la plus jeune le sortons bien sûr la
plus jeune c'est dans l'équipe qui sera
mangé ses dents lui qui guidera manger
ou erronées
au hall au rouge jaune sauf au revoir
boulet lui
[Musique]
nous voilà voilà
vous êtes des quotas je n'aurais plus
optimiste et je ne change pas c'est vrai
ça à la va vite rejoindre ton patron non
on va se coucher pas seul intégra pour
te faire plaisir au negro nono bonne
nuit
bonne nuit les petits d'or publie
[Musique]
oh
oooh
on
allons en route le nours en route ce que
j'ai eu chaud aux patrons encore un peu
il me manger
mais ils sont quand même bien mignons
ces petits ce que je lisais en route
nord ce que je les ai alors on y va pas
trop et quand tu voudras mon cher north
roues
banier enfin fait pour
[Musique]
oh